I must fight together now okay
[Music]
and it doesn't time
[Applause]
that Kony hi everyone is Charlie
surprise surprise we got a brand new
Game of Thrones Season 8 trailer so we
got to break it down it starts off with
a little bit of the same footage they
mix in a bunch of new stuff and some new
dialogue from Tyrion to I'm doing Game
of Thrones videos all season long and
for the prequel show that's gonna
premiere next year so be sure to
subscribe to get everything if you're
brand new to the channel there's a new
round of the book giveaway to you start
off with the same scene of Jon Snow
Daenerys marching in with the unsullied
legions and the Dothraki bloodrider
'he's behind them to Winterfell this is
very early in episode 1 then you get a
brand new scene of Tyrion and that
voiceover from him addressing all the
northern Lords in the Great Hall at
Winterfell we must fight together now or
die in the background you can see
Daenerys and Sansa both sitting at the
head of the table you can't see Jon Snow
but he'd also be sitting at the table as
well so either they put their
differences aside or they're just
affording to nourish the respect and
recognition of someone of her rank of
course it seems like Tyrion is trying to
calm everyone down they wouldn't give
him a line of dialogue like that on
those things were very contentious
because they don't want to trust in Eris
because she's a Targaryen and most of
the northern Lords did not go north of
the wall to see that white the wildlings
are some of the only people that totally
believed Jon Snow and everything that
he's said about them a lot of the lords
are actually more worried about what's
going on in King's Landing and more
focused on the Iron Throne although it
does seem like they're willing to go
along with Jon Snow they're just more
focused on the stuff that's happening
with the living they're not so focused
on the army of the dead yet the king in
the north
should stay in the north we did not
choose you to rule us milady but perhaps
we should
the Knights of the Vale came here for
you
they'd you stop that's why Tyrion is
trying to shake some sense at them like
look stop arguing
they're coming we're all gonna die
unless we band together there's another
shot of the little boy climbing up on
the rooftop to watch them pass by just
like branded during the pilot episode to
watch Robert Baratheon's procession
march in there are a lot of people that
thinks that these are Theon's ships not
Euron's because it's a little hard to
distinguish the biggest difference is
that you're on ships are way more
heavily armored and there's way more of
them this is another shot of that Canyon
run with drogon and regal just flying
chasing each other through like I said
it's implied that Jon Snow is actually
riding one of the dragons and they just
digitally remove them or in this footage
they haven't added them yet they just
plucked this from earlier in the process
before they finished editing everything
this is a brand-new shot of Jon Snow and
Daenerys staring moodily at a fireplace
maybe this is after she finds out about
the r plus l equals j of it all she has
that brand-new braid too she looks like
she's wearing her new outfit but as John
walks away you can see her just continue
staring deep into the fire like she has
no idea how to process everything so it
just seems like a big info-dump moment
where he tells her and she just
completely shook to her core there's
another shot of the Dragons flying over
sont over Winterfell she looks up as
they fly by then you get the wide shot
you cut to a shot of beric Dondarrion
with his flaming sword down at
Winterfell so maybe he made it there
just in time to let them know that the
army is coming but it seems like they're
up at the wall in this other trailer
shot up here so he must make it down to
Winterfell really fast by the end of
episode two the fact that his sword is
flaming though implies this is during
the battle so I'm guessing that this
shot in particular is from episode 3
this other shot of the Hound 2 that we
saw in the last trailer a little bit
brighter seems like it's also from
episode 3 during the big battle because
he's freaking out with all this fire
around him this is a shot of Daenerys
with her white winter coat in the
courtyard in the middle of daytime it's
either episode 1 or episode 2 it seems
like she's just walking around getting
her bearings inspecting everything
because by the time we get to episode 2
they'll be full-on preparing for the
actual assault there's a brain who shot
at the unsullied legions forming their
phalanx getting ready for a big attack
this looks like it's after the battle
has already begun Jon Snow taking a
giant swipe with Longclaw also during
the battle this shot of Cersei could be
happening during any of the first couple
of f
so it's really hard to place her she's
just in her normal outfit this shot of
Davos tyrion and varys
looks like it's them watching the
Dragons fly overhead and I think this is
actually subtle confirmation that Jon
Snow is riding one of them and that's
why varus's jaw is on the ground because
varus is not surprised by the Dragons
he's been around them for a long time
now
so watching dragons fly overhead would
not be a big surprise for him one of the
few things that would make him freak out
like this seeing them is as if somebody
unexpected was riding one of them and
that person would probably be Jon Snow
what I think they'll probably do though
is I think they'll try to keep any
actual footage of him on dragon back out
of the big trailers before the season
starts because it sounds like it's meant
to be this really big payoff because he
has Targaryen blood and is him embracing
his heritage the Dragons even purr like
big cats when he's nearby
so all this big said at the last couple
of seasons seems to imply that he's
going to be riding one of these dragons
and obviously it would be a Ragle the
one that's named after his father
there's another shot of the unsullied
legions during the big episode three
battle during a different point another
shot of Jon Snow also during that battle
somewhere else charging across the field
same episode but different footage of
Arya than we've seen before on the
battlements up at Winterfell just part
of that really big scene where you see
her twirling that Pike around probably
has some dragon glass attached to it
then that same scene of one of the white
Walker generals just marching into frame
with the rest of the army of the Dead
behind him so everybody freaked out in
the comments about this brand new
footage do you actually think that this
shot here is them watching Jon Snow
riding a dragon in any other big Easter
eggs that you think you spotted but I
think the real key new footage here is
Jon in Daenerys by this fire side here
in this really very serious-looking
moment Tyrion in the Great Hall trying
to rally everyone to comment cause then
big surprise Barrack finally making it
down to Winterfell during this big
episode three battle he is really high
on my death predictions list I mean if
they're gonna get rid of someone really
early in the season he's already died so
many times before what's one more time
like how many times will the Lord of
Light bring him back how many times has
the Lord brought him back six
corners on Costas tower I XE really
really tired it's implied that there is
some kind of limit because when he talks
about it to Melisandre he talks about
pieces of him getting chipped away he
barely feels like himself he's a
completely different person with a
different personality than he was before
he died the first time this is also a
big deal for Jon Snow - although to a
much lesser degree the producers have
said even though we're well past that
book moment because he hasn't been
brought back in the books yet that when
he does come back he feels fundamentally
different and unsettled although you
don't always get that from Kit Harington
in the new season seven scenes during
season six after he came back there were
a couple moments where he just felt
shook like what just happened I don't
understand any of this but by the time
we got to the end of that season he
seemed like he had grown comfortable
with it and they just didn't address it
that much openly but there were a couple
scenes during season 7 when they brought
it back up when he first met with
Daenerys sir Davos said that he
literally took a knife in the heart for
his men Daenerys got really curious and
almost pushed him on it but John stopped
sir Davos before he started to explain
more because he was ready to spill beans
about everything that happened at the
wall she brought it back up again after
he met drogon but they were cut off when
Sir Jorah walked up so they haven't
officially had that conversation yet
I'll be interested to see if they
directly addressed that in a season 8
scene where they talk about resurrection
in Daenerys his presence because not all
the characters totally understand what
happened bran Melisandre beric
Dondarrion Samwell and maybe a couple
other people are the only ones that
understand what happened to him there's
only two more weeks to go before the
season starts so I'm not expecting a ton
more footage maybe a couple more promos
like this and some more behind the
scenes stuff so whatever ends up
happening I will totally make videos for
it leave all your video requests in the
comments below or if you have any
questions about the footage during this
promo there'll be more Game of Thrones
videos posting this week I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post my next one
while you wait for everything click here
for my new preview video from episode 1
in episode 2 and click here for all my
other Game of Thrones season 8 trailer
Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
tonight